[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it is
the bible
the word of god welcome to bible answers
live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
the azam
super yacht is the biggest yacht in the
world
azam it means resolute in english it's
an amazing vessel that was built for
sheikh mohammed bin zayed prince of abu
dhabi
launched on april 5 2013 at 590
feet that's like two football fields the
azam is the longest private motor yacht
in the world
azam is not only the longest but also
one of the fastest
with 94 000 horsepower this vessel is
capable of 37 miles an hour you could
ski barefoot behind it
at top speed it consumes 13 tons of fuel
per hour
and the yacht accommodates a large open
plan main saloon with accommodations for
36 guests and those are very luxury
accommodations
and up to 80 crew one yacht there's a
bulletproof master suite
and she carries a missile defense system
and a small submarine
this super ship costs approximately 600
million dollars to build
and it costs 50 million dollars a year
to maintain
the ship is fully staffed ready to serve
all the time
should the prince fly in unannounced the
refrigerator and the pantry is kept
stocked with the best and freshest food
the generator running and the sheets are
turned down nightly
so they're ready all the time for an
unexpected visit
from the prince you know the bible says
that christian believers should be ready
at all times for the coming of the lord
stay with us friends we'll learn more on
this edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and
practical answers to your bible
questions
welcome listening friends and if you've
got bible questions that's what we're
doing here you just simply give us a
call at our phone number
which is 800
with your bible questions that's 800 god
says with your bible questions
and we also have another number we give
out along the way if you have uh
for our free resources this program is
also streaming right now on the amazing
facts facebook page
on the amazing facts youtube channel and
the doug batchelor facebook page and my
name is doug batchelor
my name is john ross good evening
friends pastor doug it's always great to
be able to do bible answers live talk
about the bible and take bible questions
you open the program by talking about an
amazing yacht
not just any kind of yacht but a yacht
that actually has some
protection built into it where it can
actually launch missiles or at least
protect itself from missiles coming in
that's no ordinary yacht
bulletproof master suite and all the
other things i like the idea of a
submarine i guess you could take a trip
in the submarine if you're on the yacht
but the amount of money spent just to
maintain the yacht and then just to keep
it ready
the the crew has to be on standby all
the time because
you know you never know when the prince
is going to come and they're going to
have to be ready to go
and you mentioned that well in the bible
it tells us we need to be ready because
we're about to go that's right yeah the
prince of abu dhabi has just very high
security hence i suppose they've got the
missile
launch system the bulletproof glass he's
one of the wealthiest people in the
world
and he doesn't want everyone to know
where he's at so
he just drops in sometimes
and and they've received this very short
notice the prince will be here
so they've got to keep it ready and act
like he's coming all the time
now you've been to the seychelles
islands and karen and i were there a
couple of years ago and we saw the yacht
from a distance but uh boy i'll tell you
i
i thought to myself is that a cruise
ship or is that and they said no that is
the
yacht for the prince of abu dhabi and
they
they keep they spend a fortune keeping
it ready all the time
for an unexpected visit you know jesus
says in matthew 24 verse 44
therefore speaking of the second coming
therefore you
also be ready for the son of man is
coming at an
hour you do not expect jesus warns about
the
the unfaithful servant who thinks his
lord has delayed his coming and because
of that he eats and drinks
drinks with the drunken and he mistreats
the other servants
he wants us to have an attitude of
expectancy that he could come anytime
and folks might wonder are there some
signs given in the bible how do we know
that the lord is coming
how do we know that the real lord is
coming satan's going to impersonate
jesus and does the bible say anything
about
is it soon we have a study guide it's
called the ultimate deliverance it's all
about the second coming and we'll talk
about the signs of the second coming the
manner of christ coming
along with how we can be ready for the
coming of jesus
we'll send this to anyone it's free all
you have to do is call and ask the
number to call is 800-835-6747 that is
our resource phone line
again that number is 800-835-6747
you can ask for the study guide it's
called the ultimate deliverance we'll be
happy to send it to you
now pasadec we've got folks who are
listening not only in the united states
and canada but even outside of north
america
and of course we can't mail the free
offer all the way all over the world but
you can go to the amazing facts
website and you'll be able to read it
there for free
just go to amazingfacts.org well before
we get to the questions
let's start with the word of prayer and
then we'll take our first call of this
evening
dear father we thank you again that
we're able to open up your word and
study together and as we always do we
want to recognize that
father this is your book and we need the
spirit to guide us be with those who are
listening wherever they might be
and lord lead us to a clearer
understanding of what the bible teaches
in jesus name amen amen
okay we're ready to go to the phone
lines our first call of this evening is
noah
and he is listening in illinois noah
welcome to the program hi pastor jose hi
pastor ross
hi thanks for calling yes you're welcome
my question is did adam see eve
be out of the clothes coming out of the
robes of righteousness and is that why
he ate the forbidden fruit
well you know it doesn't sound like
well when adam and eve were created let
me just explain for everybody listening
god created adam and eve were these
artificial garments of light is what
most scholars believe they were covered
with a splendor a glory
when moses talked to the lord he was
shining with light with glory and so
they had these like robes of light you
might say
talks about them in revelation talks
about jesus his
garments were shining with light when he
was on the mount of transfiguration
after eve sinned we believe the light
went dim but probably didn't happen
until adam had also sinned he went right
from the serpent and the tree and
tasting the fruit to adam and gave it to
him
and it says after that they realized
they were naked so the way it's written
in the bible makes it sound like
after adam and eve both sinned the light
evaporated
and then they sensed their shame and
that cold chill
that they didn't feel before and then of
course the bible begins
uh with a story in a garden where adam
and eve sinned
they lost that robe of righteousness and
the bible ends once again with the
redeemed
in the garden now in the new jerusalem
by the tree of life
revelation says they receive once again
those robes of righteousness those robes
of light
so full circle that we find there in the
bible amen thank you for your call noah
we have alan listening in oregon alan
welcome to the program
hi uh pastor doug pastor ross how are
you this evening
doing great good question my question
my question yes is um about baptism
specifically
um i know um what matthew 28 19 and 20
says
and i my wife and myself and our
daughters were all christian
um i was baptized when i was nine years
old
and i um i've had you know
jesus in my heart this whole time but
i've you know fallen away a little bit
over the years and then
i rededicated myself and my wife and my
daughter have not yet been baptized but
we
they do want to be baptized and i i want
i feel like i want to be you know
re-baptized as my my recommitment and
my question is basically are we allowed
to
as christians can we baptize each other
or does there need to be
a like a pastor involved that's that's
yeah good question uh well first of all
it's great that you're
you're considering re-baptism if if you
did drift away for a while
and your family's making the decision
for the first time
you can join them in that there are
examples in the bible of people being
re-baptized like in acts chapter 19.
um but yeah absolutely
uh you know you want to get that new
beginning and
uh the question is though can you
baptize yourself
i spaced
yeah i would say no um because in the
bible
the lord authorizes people to baptize
his baptize
is sort of a gateway into the body of
christ
and if if everybody's sort of baptizing
each other without them being kind of
cleared
it's like that's why pastors do weddings
it's a sacred ceremony it's a covenant
whenever you sign a covenant there are
witnesses and someone who officiates
and the person who officiates is
ostensibly supposed to have some
knowledge of what that covenant means
and so typically jesus had either the
deacons elders evangelists like philip
would baptize or the apostles in fact
you can read where they were a bunch of
people in samaria that had accepted
christ and they sent to jerusalem
that the apostles would come and baptize
them that they could receive the holy
spirit
so they saw that there was something in
those who had been authorized doing it
you know we do have a book it's called
baptism is it really necessary and
alan will be happy to send this to you
or to your family members or to anyone
who would like to learn more about
baptism
it's free the number to call is
800-835-6747
and again just ask for the book it's
called baptism is it really necessary
now alan do you have a church that you
go to
um we we actually don't actually we um
we moved um to a pretty far place in
oregon it's john day oregon
oh i know where that is and it's uh yeah
we're about we only have about 1700
people here and
we've actually we had two radio stations
here and one of them
actually played three abn so we actually
have been listening at 3abn for for a
while now
and we've learned we've learned so much
and so we're actively you know looking
for that right church and been praying
about it but we don't have one yeah it'd
be really good to connect with the
church that's why
i wondered if you were wondering about
baptizing yourself i thought well maybe
you don't know a pastor they can help
you right now
it'd be good for you to track down a
pastor and plan it and make a special
occasion of it
and connect with a local church family
where you can go to church on a regular
basis and i think i know of one or two
churches in
in john day oregon but it is a small
little town i know that
well thank you for calling all right
thanks for call alan we've got uh glenn
who is listening in california glenn
welcome to the program
hi good evening my first time listening
all right so um
so i good question about uh creation do
you guys believe
god created in six literal days or do
you have some other
rationale well what we believe is worth
a nickel
uh jesus tells us that if you don't
believe moses and you don't believe me
so jesus says you know if we don't
believe what's written in the writings
of moses
moses is explicit that the lord created
the world in six
24-hour periods they couldn't have been
ages or eons
or maybe i should pause before i
elaborate is that what you understand
precisely that is what i think that the
genesis
record articulates that god created in
six
24-hour days yeah absolutely because uh
you know the lord makes a vegetation on
the third day but he doesn't make the
sun moon and stars until the fourth day
so you can't have eons going by with the
vegetables
you know we got plants in our house if
we don't water them once a week they die
so you know there has to be light for
those plants to survive it couldn't have
been
you know months or thousands of years
they were six literal 24-hour days
matter of fact the bible says in the
morning and the evening were the first
day of the second year the third day and
you only have
one morning one evening in a 24-hour
period so it had to be 24 hours
in literal days and we'd have a book
it's called amazing wonders of creation
and it talks about some of the things
that god has made that clearly point to
a designer god a
designer creator and we'll be happy to
make that available to anyone we don't
always offer this so
take advantage of it the number to call
is
mail to anyone in 800-835-6747 america
outside of north america just go to the
amazing facts website
we've got raymond listening in la
raymond welcome to the program
thank you um
raymond you got to get real close to
your phone we're hearing a lot of road
noise
how's that is that better well you said
go ahead state your question then we'll
mute you and i'll repeat it for everyone
okay um you know we uh i just had a
question about
once dave to always say versus um
frank wanted your thoughts on that okay
so raymond's asking about the statement
of you know once saved
always saved uh in contrast with the
idea that you know
um we have free will and that a person
can lose their salvation
well i think the bible is pretty clear
that if we put our hands in the hand of
the lord he says i will never let go of
you
so you can have assurance of your
relationship with the lord but we never
lose our freedom to let go of him
that's why the bible says you know do
not turn back
uh do not be like the the dog that was
uh returning to its vomit or the pig
that was washed a wallowing in the mire
and hebrews chapter i think it's chapter
six verse four it talks about
if a person has tasted the holy spirit
in the
world to come if they fall away
paul says that we need to press on they
said
examine yourself lest you be found
reprobates
and so there's a lot of statements in
the bible that guard against the
the idea that you could um once you're
saved you can do whatever you want
and we are not predetermined who is
going to be saved in other words god
does not look down
from heaven and say i'm going to make
this person i'm going to make them a
sinner and i'm going to make it where
they can't be saved
and then i'm going to punish them for
sinning because then it's like god is
saying i'm making them where they have
no choice
about doing my will and then i'm going
to punish them for not doing my will
so god then would sort of be like an
accomplice to the crime of sin
everybody has a freedom of choice and
that's why
joshua says choose who you will serve
peter tells us god is not willing ii
peter chapter 3 that any
should perish he wants all to come to
repentance and
paul tells us in timothy god who would
have all men to be saved
well clearly not all are saved that's
not god's will it's not his will that
any are lost
but you know some people make that
choice
we have a book pastor doug it's called
can a saved man choose to be lost
and that deals with the very question
that raymond is asking
if you'd like to receive that book the
number to call is
the book can a 800-835-6747 man choose
to be lost and we'll
put in the mail and send it to you
anywhere in north america and again if
you're outside of north america
take a look at our website we want to
thank raymond for his call we've got
john
also listening in california john
welcome to the program
hello hi thanks for calling
thank you my question is regarding
the the names of the apostles in the
bible
such as matthew mark luke and john those
are
english names how come they don't have
the typical names of the time like
bartholomew
nebuchadnezzar lazarus hezekiah alves
yeah well when you when you're looking
at the names in the bible
uh you've got the challenge of dealing
with four languages in our case
because you've got hebrew aramaic
greek and english
and um so like if you wanted to say
jesus in uh spanish or in latin it's
jesus if you were to say jesus
in english it's more like jesus
it's a little different from what we
even say rather in greek rather it'd be
more like jesus in english it's jesus
if you're going to say in hebrew it's
yeshua and so whenever the translators
translate names
you know they all come out a little
different i i've got a lot of friends
and when we go to mexico they don't call
george george they call him jorge
so that's how they say george and so
you're going to see that as you go from
language to language pronunciation of
some words is very difficult in certain
languages
i worked with the navajo indians for
about a year and a half on
a mission and they couldn't say doug
they called me duck
and i just got used to it
and you know i think pasadena also some
of these common bible names like matthew
mark luke and john
lazarus or some of them nathaniel and
others uh stephen
um they have almost become english names
because
of the influence that the bible has
actually very similar right
the names the bible is the influence the
bible has had in the english-speaking
world
that today when you think of for example
stephen you think of that as being an
english name
uh you're not always connected with
whatever it originally sounded like in
the hebrew or in the greek
i think it was just stefanos stefanos
yeah yeah very close
all right well thanks for your call john
uh we've got let's see next call
is uh june calling from florida
june welcome to the program yes hi good
evening
pastor doug and pastor ross evening
yeah thank you so much for all you guys
do um
to get the people on drive for jesus to
come so here's my question
uh it's revelations chapter 17
that's actually there's a passage that
always like you know
i wanted to know about it verse 10 it
says there are seven kings
five are fallen and one is
and the other is not yet come and when
he comes
uh he must continue a short space
and talk about this one i need to know
is that a prophecy that
that um any of this prophecy
i need to know if any of the past so
what is this passage really talking
about
all right great uh we'll have to give
you a quick answer because
revelation 17 is such a it's a a big
subject
but it's talking about this beast power
the woman is sitting upon this beast
with seven heads and ten horns
you find that same beast in revelation
chapter 13
and you find that beast in revelation
chapter 12 and you find a similar beast
is it then
daniel 7 pastor ross the 10 corner from
the earth
yeah chapter 12. daniel i'm saying it's
awesome yeah and
daniel 7. yeah so this is the beast of
bible prophecy that beast rides upon
seven kingdoms that have persecuted
god's people
and it starts out with the kingdoms that
have persecuted
literal israel and then it goes into the
kingdoms and ended up persecuting
spiritual israel or the church
and those would be egypt assyria
babylon medo-persia greece i just named
five kingdoms it says five are fallen
these five kingdoms were in past history
when john had the vision of revelation
then he goes on and he says and one is
and that one that is well that's the
roman empire that had imprisoned him and
killed jesus
the other is not yet come when rome fell
there wasn't another empire but it was
sort of subsumed
by a religious movement namely the roman
church
and they kind of ruled through europe
during the dark ages
it says it would receive a deadly wound
it comes back again
and says he's also the eighth because
it's wounded and it comes back
so you've got uh
those there you've got seven kingdoms
and the seventh is also the eighth
some of this of course is still being
played out right now in history
and uh but most of these prophecies in
in are in the past
now we have a bible lesson that talks
about some of those kingdoms don't we
we do we have one actually it's not one
that we offer too often but
i think we can get it for you it's the
woman rides the beast oh the book
yeah the woman the beast and the dragon
you know pastor we've got a documentary
i was just watching it yesterday
called uh the woman the beast how does
it go bright beast in babylon there it
is
the bride the beast in babylon covers
this and you can actually view that i
believe it's available on
online on youtube and it covers all of
these prophecies revelation 12 and
others
it's just a great important theme
to study go to youtube the bride the
beast in babylon june and you'll
you'll see that they're very helpful
okay next caller that we have let's see
we've got uh
zavor listening from pennsylvania xavier
welcome to the program
hi there um hi pastor ross uh hi pastor
doug uh honestly just
amazing to speak with you i'm gonna i'm
gonna be quick about examination so
people wanna ask
ask you questions so um one of the
things that i am
really uh wondering about is
how did civilizations and cultures that
did not
meet with uh meet with missionaries or
or ministers or whatnot
how did they get saved because i i wrote
a paper a little while ago about like
the
aztec empire and how they're worshiping
demons and you know kids are getting
sacrificed stuff and i'm just wondering
like are all these people
lost like how i'm so curious what you
guys think about that all right you know
that is that's a complicated subject
first i want to make it clear
nobody is saved without jesus the bible
tells us that there is no other name
given among men whereby we must see be
saved
but there will be some people that are
saved through christ that maybe didn't
know about him
clearly people in the old testament i
mean you know god had faithful people
you've got the canaanite woman you've
got ruth and you've got abraham and
you've got naaman and
they had not heard of jesus yet but
they'll be in heaven the bible's really
clear
so but when they get to heaven they're
there because of his sacrifice
that had not been made yet there are
people in foreign lands
that are walking in all of the light
that god gives them now these are you
know rare occasions i don't want to make
it sound like missionaries can stay home
but there will be some people i think
angel spoke to them and they followed
the light that god gave them
and you know jesus said if you walk in
the light
as he is in the light the blood of jesus
christ cleanses you from all sin
he jesus tells us in the resurrection
those that have had done
good will come forth in the resurrection
of life and those that have done evil
the resurrection of damnation
and so i think that god is going to just
extend mercy to some of these people in
these dark countries
but a lot of them will be lost because
they were just held captive in darkness
but i think there are exceptions yes god
judges us
based upon what we know and based upon
what we can know
so how do we respond to the light that
we have yeah i think even in romans 1 he
says even the barbarians when they
obey the law that they know
you know are living up to what they have
and at the times of ignorance god winks
that
but now he commands people everywhere to
repent
so i i think that god is going to be
merciful i'm not one of these pastors
who believes that
you know everybody who lived in the 4
000 years before jesus in north america
and south america and australia and
africa
are all going to be doomed i think that
uh
we can't underestimate the ability of
the lord to speak through them
through supernatural means and and reach
them
does that mean yeah it really did
seriously thank you so much for both of
your wisdoms i really appreciate it
thank you
thank you well pastor do we have time
for one more before the break i think we
do
yeah we've got daniel listening in
florida daniel welcome to the program
yeah hello yeah you're here
yeah so my question was um regarding sin
i was curious
are some sins more punishable than
others because
in some parts of the bible the god would
strike down somebody for like lying i
think that was a nias
but like if we lie now we don't get
struck down so
can you explain that please yeah that's
that's true there are varying degrees of
sin you can read in luke 12
47 the servant who knew his master's
will
and did not prepare himself to do
according to his will shall be
beaten with many stripes but then
conversely he that did not know his
master's will
and did things wrong he's beaten with
few stripes these are the words of jesus
there are varying degrees of punishment
god is also more severe like with
ananias and sapphira
and with azza and nadab and a baihu
these are people who were stricken
by the lord because they were they knew
better they had been exposed to the holy
spirit they were living in the presence
of the lord and they sinned in a
high-handed way right there in the
presence of god
so the bible says to whom much is given
much is required
and you know the lord is going to expect
more of those who have more and i think
at the beginning
of the christian church like you say
pastor doug there was a need to just
reaffirm um the faithfulness of
believers that we need to be committed
to the lord and you think of anania and
sapphira that was
set forth as an example to those early
believers in the christian church
yeah and so and there are even varying
degrees of sin
um you know all sin is deadly and you
know we want to make that clear
jesus came and he died for all kinds of
sin
but you can read in the bible where
certain kings it says he committed a
grievous sin and the lord identifies
certain sins as
iniquity where others are more like a
transgression
and then there are some things god calls
an abomination so
god even uses different language to talk
about the intensity of different kinds
of sin
you folks are asking great questions
don't give up we got another half of the
program to come
we're going to hit the ground running
after a brief break
call your friends tell them to tune in
we'll be right back
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
did you know that noah was present at
the birth of abraham
ok maybe he wasn't in the room but he
was alive and probably telling stories
about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore major bible events
and characters
enhance your knowledge of the bible and
draw closer to god's word
go deeper visit biblehistory.com
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index words of
christ in red
chronology of the old testament along
with doug batchelor's how to study the
bible feature and much more
call us at af bookstore to learn more
about it at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on
bible answers live order your copy today
at
afbookstore.com or by calling 1-800
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country
come together to reveal the hidden
history of the book of revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects
this 95-minute masterpiece brings to
life the book of revelation
like never before revelation is no
longer a mystery
get your copy today visit itunes or
you're afbookstore.com to bible answers
live where every question answered
provides a clearer picture of god
and his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and that's why we're here
to do our best to answer your bible
questions if you have a bible question
you can call in the number is
800 god says and that's 800-463-7297
with your bible questions and we're also
streaming now on facebook the amazing
facts facebook page the doug batchelor
facebook page and it is live
on youtube and we're soon to be going on
television as well so you can both
listen and watch what's happening here
i am doug batchelor my name is john ross
and pass today we've got a number of
folks who've lined up with their bible
questions we're going to go to our first
question that i have here let's go to
louisa in
texas luisa welcome to the program
hello hello hi you're on
hi pastor ross hello pastor dodd i'm so
like
excited because i met practice bachelor
when i was
21 in new york city in a really nice
convention he did for a couple of days
there oh that was in uh yeah
about 20 years ago it was a little bit
over 20 years and i remember my daughter
was
a very baby and she was in the baby room
babysitting room with your babies with
your kids they were literal
at that time so that was a great um i
remember you and
and your wife exactly like today and
john beautiful singer
yeah yeah i bought the city i can't
remember everything it's been it's
amazing
i'm a little excited about that but
anyways it's been 25 years i'm 45 now
i've learned so much with you and my
question every time i have a question i
go to youtube
or your channels and i ask that's that
that would know
um when a lot of us say
a lot about this subject but it's a very
every pastor has a different and i want
to know what you think
when will be the right moment or when
god wants
us christians to abandon the cities
finally when will be that now are you
living in new york city
i live in houston oh you live in houston
that's that's a big city too
um yes you know let me first for our
friends listening let me read a verse to
you from matthew 24 15
he's speaking of the signs of his coming
and jesus said when you see the
abomination of desolation spoken of by
daniel the prophet
stand in the holy place whoever reads
let him understand
let those that are in judea flee to the
mountains let him who is on the housetop
not go down and take anything out of his
house and so in the same way god told
lot
to flee into the mountains and he's told
people he told the apostles
when the romans surrounded jerusalem
that it would
they would have a signal when they were
to flee out of the city because
jerusalem was going to be
besieged and destroyed and it was in the
last days
god's people are going to be hedged in
with religious
laws and it's going to be a signal when
they start telling us that they're
creating laws that require us to break
the law of god
you may not want to be in the populated
areas i mean we even saw during this
pandemic
that you know we saw people slugging it
out in the marketplace over toilet paper
i couldn't believe that that civilized
people would
go to the mat fighting with each other
over toilet paper
can you imagine what it's going to be
like in the big cities
if you know we had somebody did a cyber
attack on our
our petroleum plants and there was a gas
shortage becky some of our employees
actually couldn't drive home because
they couldn't buy gas
i thought what will happen in our big
cities if there are no
trucks delivering food for a week
just think about the chaos and you'd
like to think everyone's going to be
nice
and civilized and good citizens
but we've seen that not everyone acts
that way and
i thought i don't want to be in a city
when that happens so
how do you know when to go um
well you know for one thing if god opens
the door for you to have
a decent income and be in a more rural
environment it's probably better for a
family
uh you know we're right now on the
outskirts of sacramento but
where we're located right now we're just
a few minutes from the mountains
um but yeah i i think that the signal is
as we see
the governments of the world beginning
to make religious laws that restrict the
the rights of christians that'll be a
signal
now do we have a book on that you know i
got a sermon called when to leave the
city
yeah maybe that's the best one i don't
think we have a book specifically that
deals with that subject i've got a whole
sermon on that if you just go to youtube
and write doug batchelor when to leave
the cities i know it's there because
people have shown it to me
so all right well thanks for your call
there louisa we've got joe listening in
arkansas
joe welcome to the program thank you
uh my question i just had a question
about
romans 14 5 and 6. i just wanted you to
kind of explain what that's talking
about
sure romans 14 5 and 6 and
let me read this for our friends who are
listening one person esteems one day
above another
another person esteems every day alike
let each one be fully convinced in his
own mind
he who observes the day observes it to
the lord he who does not observe the day
to the lord he does not observe it
uh he who eats he eats to the lord and
he gives god thanks and he do
who does not eat to the lord he does not
eat and he gives god thanks
all right what paul was talking about
here in romans is the
christians in rome they had been pagans
they accepted christ
were being approaded by the jewish
christians some jews had accepted jesus
and the jewish
christians were saying you need to keep
all these feast days
and passover day of atonement what we
call yom kippur
and the other jewish feasts i said you
need to keep the feast days
and now there's certainly nothing wrong
with doing that but you know now that
jesus died on a cross he's the
fulfillment of that we don't need to
keep those days
they were also the jewish christians
were telling some of the gentile
christians they said
you can't eat anything that is
sacrificed in the marking place
that's butchered there because they
offer it to pagan gods
well paul is saying look if if if you're
going to eat
the food there and he's talking about
clean food of course if you're going to
eat the meat there they kill the goat or
chicken or something
and you ask god to bless it and you give
god thanks and it doesn't bother your
conscience that it had been offered to
buddha or jupiter or some god said then
go ahead
but if it bothers your conscience if
it's not of faith then don't eat it
but don't condemn your brother that does
eat it so
he's really dealing with jews that were
the jewish christians that were trying
to keep
the gentile christians keeping some of
these ceremonial laws
and i'm wondering if we've got a book on
feast days and sabbaths that talks about
that
does that help help joe
yeah that helps a lot i just i had a
friend that
that thinks that that was talking about
the weekly sabbath and i was just
wondering
how to tell him that that wasn't what it
was talking about
yeah well for one thing uh just remind
him the word sabbath appears nowhere in
the text
it talks about a day and and i've never
ever heard
a pastor a sunday keeping pastor or a
sabbath-keeping pastor that stands up in
his congregation and says
hey if you guys feel like coming to
church you go ahead if you don't don't
they don't believe that so you notice
that
they never use that verse when they're
talking about keeping sunday
they only use that verse when they're
talking about keeping sabbath it had
nothing to do with saturday or sunday it
had to do with the annual jewish feasts
that they were debating the book you're
referring to past today is called feast
days and sabbaths are they still binding
and i think this verse is actually
addressed in the book the number to call
is 800-835-6747 that is the resource
phone line
you can just ask the operator to please
send you the book feast days and
sabbaths we'll be happy to send it to
you we'll get in the mail
thank you for your call joe let's see we
got paul listening in
is it indiana paul welcome to the
program
hi thank you i had a question about
when moses received the ten commandments
on
mount sinai and i was wondering who was
with him in exodus 19 verse 24
it seems like the lord says to go down
and and get aaron and bring him up and
then
i was also questioning if the people
could hear him because in exodus 2018
it says that they were afraid and stood
far off so just curious
what you think about those yeah that's a
good question and then there's a place
where it says
nobody was to come up except moses but
then clearly
joshua went up with him and that's
because they said they used to sort of
figure that a man
and his servant or his apprentice they
thought about as you know one person
really
but it does sound like that
moses at one point moses and the 70
elders and that's including you know
aaron they were able to approach beyond
the foot of the mountain
to approach the mountain to talk to the
lord
most of the people stood far off and
they said don't let god speak to us
anymore you speak to us they were
terrified
but some of the elders drew closer to
the mountain
and joshua must have gone up the
mountain because he met moses he said
there's a sound of war in the camp
joshua was not in the camp
but he wasn't exactly where moses was
where god was talking to him so he was
joshua something of what you call a
mediator which is interesting
a mediator someone in between and jesus
is our mediator between
heaven and earth so yeah it's a great
question
all right thank you do you think with
with aaron as well do you think he
was up there or yeah at one point i
think aaron did go up and because of
course he's the high priest and god did
send aaron
in with moses to talk to pharaoh and
many times when
um it talks about moses said something
aaron was actually translating
you remember god said moses said i'm
slow of speech and he said i'll send
your brother
and he can be a mouth for you because
moses had not been speaking egyptian for
40 years and he said how can i talk to
pharaoh it's all my
my egyptian is all mixed up with my
midianite right now and
he said well your brother you can talk
to him and he'll
speak for you so aaron was often with
moses on those occasions
you know if you if you look a little
further in chapter 24 of exodus verse 9
this is the second time after the law
was given to moses the first time was
broken
and then later we have in verse 9 where
moses went up god said bring aaron
nadab abahu and 70 of the elders of
israel
and they went up and then at some point
god called moses to come up even
further by himself and then joshua
separated with moses and then at that
point joshua stayed somewhere as well
and moses was the one who finally
entered into the presence of god and got
the
by then of course it was god riding on
the stones which were made by moses so
a little further in the chapter explains
a little more of that picture of this
yeah very good all right thank you so
much
hey thank you appreciate your question
all right we've got our caller from
sacramento javitian
is listening in sacramento javition
welcome to the program
hey how are you doing good now we want
to hear you say your name because we're
probably saying it wrong
uh it's jataveon okay thanks so much
all right and i'm and i'm actually in
dallas right now um
oh okay that's actually eastern
sacramento but go ahead
all right all right my question is um
so uh for the last few weeks uh i've
i've been uh
i've been praying and uh staying trying
to stay in the word but uh
i have a lot of thoughts of the things
that i've done when i was younger
and uh they're just uh you know it's
kind of like bombarding my brain and
it's kind of like uh you know
making me feel bad and i'm i'm not i'm
not the type of person
i'm not that type of person anymore and
i just want to see
do you have any verses or uh anything
that you can uh you know
uh like anything encouraging that you
can say to me that uh you know
like to help me on this journey to stay
close to god and uh you know
what's that verse in philippians pastor
uh ross
where he said whatsoever things is that
philippians 4
whatsoever finally brethren here it is
philippians 4 verse 8
finally brethren whatever things are
true whatever things are noble
whatever things are just whatever things
are pure whatever things are lovely
whatever things are of good report if
there's any virtue
if there's anything praiseworthy
meditate on these things
the things that you've learned and
received and heard and seen in me
these do and the god of peace will be
with you
and so there's a battle you know and
unlike you all of us
you know we've got things in our past
sometimes the devil he'll
haunt us with these memories we wish we
could forget and
you'll try and pray and you say oh man
what's coming into my mind while i'm
praying and
you know it's just a discipline of
overcoming evil with good
you can't have darkness and light invade
the same space if you want darkness
out of a room you shine light on it you
cannot have
air and water in the same cup if you
want the air out you pour water into the
cup and the air goes out
so keep filling yourself with that which
is good and it will gradually
expel what's evil and it doesn't happen
right away because you
now need to fill your mind with the good
thoughts and memories you know pastor
we've got a book it's called who do you
think you are and he talks about
our thoughts and how we need to think on
the things that are pleasing
to god and i think you'll find that
helpful we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks you can ask
for the book written by pastor dec it's
called who do you think you are
the number is 800-835-6747
and again ask for that book it's called
who do you think you are i think you'll
enjoy
reading that we've got joe listening in
oregon joe welcome to the program
good afternoon or evening gentlemen how
are you
hi doing good joe how are you doing oh
i'm doing well i'm just feeding my baby
here real quick and we're listening to
your show
and i just had a question about being
lukewarm
i know it said uh or jesus said i
believe in matthew
that it's better to be hot or cold
but not lukewarm and i just wanted to
quickly share
um i had a uh a company dinner
last friday and uh and i never prayed
before my meal i kind of felt the
pressure i didn't want to
look like that overzealous christian
person that i'm known to be
and i did and i felt am i a lukewarm
christian you know i'm not even praying
over the mule that was free
and so um it just kind of was weighing
on my heart so i just wanted to
run it by youtube gentlemen yeah well
you'll find
in revelation you're right it's in the
new testament but it's in revelation
chapter
3 and if you look at verse 14
well i'll jump down to verse 16. he says
so then because you
are lukewarm you're neither hot or cold
i will spew thee that word spew there is
vomit
out of my mouth see in bible times if
when you drink water you wanted cold
running water
otherwise it could make you you know
they had a lot of water borne diseases
if the water had been standing and tepid
you're sure to get sick so you tasted
some warm water you go oh no that's not
good
and so jesus is saying you know when the
church says i'm rich and increased with
goods and i have need of nothing and we
don't know
that we're wretched miserable poor blind
and naked
he says he can't work with that if we're
on fire working for god
the lord will empower us if we're
repentant and on our knees and asking
for mercy
he can work with us it's when we're
indifferent
and we're just comfortable in our
lostness that's when it's dangerous
and so yeah if you uh sometimes you got
to get on your knees
so that you could uh you know get up and
run for god
and that's what elijah did he spent
seven times praying on his knees and
then he ran with supernatural strength
so you might need a revival we've got a
book we can send you called 12 steps to
revival if you'd like a free copy
yes we'll be able to send that to anyone
who calls and asks i think it's uh
seven steps past the level is it twelve
i think it's twelve twelve okay i'm
looking for
the steps are growing all the time okay
i think i'm thinking
it may not be in that book list but it
is one of our little okay okay
yes i know the names for anyone wanting
to learn more about how we can
get out of a lukewarm spiritual
condition call and ask for the book on
revival 12 steps to revival the number
to call is 800-835-6747
and ask for the book on revival 12 steps
to revival
we've got tom who is listening um
from california tom welcome to the
program yes thank you very much
and i just wanted to say uh
thank you both uh pastor doug and pastor
ross for all of your biblical advice
through the years
and may god continue to bless you both
well thank you
you're welcome and my question is with
the upcoming presidential election in
whatever president may win do you feel
that they may possibly play
a future role in prophecy thank you
yeah good question uh you know i don't
know there have been several times in
the past that i was suspicious that the
presidents were going to
play a major role in prophecy i think
some of the presidents actually did
move the prophecy wheel a little bit
so you know will that next president i
mean it may be happening with the
president now will that next president
do more
uh so yeah absolutely you know pastor
doug it seems as though
we sort of on the brink that it's not
going to take much it really doesn't
matter who's in the white house
it seems that when the time's right i am
in heaven god god says now is the time
it doesn't seem as though it's going to
be very difficult for whoever is in
power whether it's republican democrat
that certain events can take place you
can have a slew of natural disasters you
can have
terrorist attack or threat we don't know
exactly what's going to
be the the trigger yeah the catalyst but
things can happen very quickly and you
know we're sort of in that waiting
pattern right now to see what's going to
happen yeah just we're right now
it's like the uh the sword of damocles
hanging by a thread
and just anything could uh we're kind of
on a seismic earth
cliff right now anything could shake it
and topple
i could see a domino effect very quickly
okay next quality that we have is uh
reuben listening from georgia ruben
welcome to the program
huh yeah you're on the air
reuben
good evening evening what's your
question tonight
well i have a couple of them let's start
with one
am i only supposed to ask one
well give us one question to start with
we'll see how much time we have
okay well
one of them is that
uh the bible says will be able to fly in
heaven right
yes will we be given wings
or will we be able to like float fly
all right let's talk about that that's
good uh you know you can read in
isaiah i'm trying to remember the verse
says we will mount up with wings like
eagles
we will run and not be weary we will
walk and not
faint and so it it does seem to imply
that uh we're gonna have the ability
where we can fly
um and it does mention wings there
in isaiah and i don't know we certainly
don't become
angels i don't know if they're wings of
light i don't know that god gives us
feathered wings it might be something
that we just can't understand right now
isaiah chapter 40 verse 31
says that we'll mount up on the wings of
eagles and you know the bible does say
pastor that when jesus comes the
righteous will be caught up to meet the
lord in the air so there will be some
flying involvement there
and when jesus went to heaven uh yeah he
didn't need angels
he didn't need wings either he just
ascended yeah so i
i think that um we'll probably be able
to do it without any kind of bird wings
because we're flying through space and
there's it's a vacuum wings don't work
there
i was going to ask what about traveling
to unknown worlds
yeah there's a song called rock of ages
it says we'll soar to worlds unknown no
that's not the bible but
good song all right did that help uh
reuben
yeah yeah do you have another quick
question yeah
oh the bonuses that there's gonna be no
sun in those stars
but there's gonna be planets how will
the planets keep on rotating
if there's no central mass of gravity
okay good question
actually there is still a sun in
revelation it tells us and pastor ross
might remind me of that verse it's like
revelation 21 or 22
it says there is no need of the sun for
the lord lights the city
some people think that means there is no
sun it doesn't say that
because you can read in malachi says the
sun of righteousness will arise with
healing in his wings
and it also says from one new moon to
another and one sabbath to another so
there are days
it says all flesh will come and worship
before me revelation 21 23
it says there's no need of the sun in
the city because the glory of god
illuminates it and yet there will still
be
days in in the earth made new yeah and
so the sun is there to hold the planets
in place
yeah and but you know god wouldn't need
that if he if god wanted to be the the
gravitational mass that would pull them
all together he could do it
all right we've got jose thanks for
calling ruben we've got jose listening
in puerto rico jose welcome to the
program
i'm hello wickl can you hear me yeah
thanks for for your patience
now don't worry uh quick question is
three parts
past present future past and underneath
uh
choose to sin choose to prefer the fruit
for the
for the tree and not trust god present
we need by the power of jesus not eat
anymore that fruit
because obviously we need to live like
that
future when there isn't seen no more
we still have the capacity the ability
to
choose okay good question so
adam and eve were given the freedom of
choice and they chose poorly
in eating the forbidden fruit we still
have a choice now because we can choose
god we can choose
jesus we can choose the devil you know
god can't force us to love if he does
that it stops being love in heaven
will we be robots or will we still have
freedom to choose well i think god
saved us because he wants our freely
given love i believe in heaven
it'll still be freely given but we'll
never have to worry about
questioning god's love again because
we'll have the history of this world
and i think it's in the book of name it
might be chapter 2 where it says sin
will not
rise the second time so
there'll be no uh reoccurrence of sin
through eternity
it says we'll you know forever and ever
we'll live
and everything will be holy and pure
in the in the new earth and so i don't
think we'll ever be tempted to
test god again for one thing the devil
will be destroyed he's cast into the
lake of fire
and the bible says never will he be
anymore so there's no one to tempt us
the verse referring to the passage is
nahum 1 9 we don't often quote the old
testament
book of name it's a small book but it's
a very important verse there it says
affliction of sin will not rise up a
second time
all right well thank you for your call
jose let's see i think we have time for
one more brandon in florida brandon
welcome to the program
good evening gentlemen thank you so much
for taking my call i appreciate it
yeah i have to make it quick here you
got about a minute
okay my question is i know physicians
and nurses
uh in conjunction with the sabbath it's
all right to go ahead and work i'm very
curious about
law enforcement and military in regard
to the sabbath
yeah well it certainly becomes a
challenge maybe you've heard of a
a movie called hacksaw ridge it's based
it's a true story based on a desmond
doss who was a friend of mine
and he volunteered during world war ii
he told him he says look i'm not going
to work on the sabbath unless i'm
healing people
and it's an emergency where i'm helping
people he was a medic
and of course he wouldn't carry a gun
either well he stood by his principles
matter of fact one battle would not
start because he says i haven't finished
my sabbath school study yet
and they held off the whole battle until
dos was done
but um so you know god expects us to
live up to our convictions there are
emergencies for police and
doctors and stuff and jesus healed
people on the sabbath
and he says if the ox is in the ditch
you don't even have to be a policeman
i've been on my way to church and seen
people break down and i've jump started
them
so i think the lord is practical but i
don't think we ought to plan
on breaking the sabbath from week to
week and i think for our own spiritual
growth pastor even
doctors and nurses if you can find
somebody else to fill in for you
at least you get a fellowship with
fellow believers you don't want to miss
every week it's important too every
sabbath yeah
hey friends we're going to run out of
time here in just a moment we want to
thank you for
uh supporting bible answers live we are
a hundred percent supported by our
viewers
and you can find out so much more about
amazing facts and what we offer
by simply going to the website it is
amazingfacts.org
god bless we'll study his word together
again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
okay friends let's start with the basics
we know we're here
but we're not here for very long so the
most important thing would be
if we could learn during this life how
to live forever
this is the central focus of amazing
facts now there's a lot of wonderful
things that christian ministries do
i believe in christian education but if
the schools
lose the message of salvation you end up
with more educated sinners
i think it's very important for us to
build churches
but if the churches lose the message of
salvation they just become buildings and
shells
i think it's important to have a medical
ministry and build hospitals
but if they separate that from the
message of salvation
you just prolong a sinner's life for a
little while that's why for years
amazing facts has made it our focus to
present the saving truth
that sets people free and friends we
want to thank you for your support
and your gifts we'll do our very best to
convert those resources into the
currency of heaven
may god bless you and keep amazing facts
in your prayers
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
would you like to know god's plan for
our troubled world and solutions for
your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned and updated
amazing facts 27 bible study guides
provide straightforward bible-based
answers that are enlightening
encouraging and easy to understand
giving you real relevant bible answers
to questions like
how can i have healthier relationships
when will jesus come
and much more order yours today by
visiting afbookstore.com
or by calling 800-538-7275
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
god's word
sign up today for this free bible study
course by calling one
eight four four two one five seven
thousand that's one eight four four
two one five seven thousand
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org